[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
well we made it through the crazy week
here we are
we
didn't think we would
it happens that way
how are all you this morning everyone's
here good morning good morning all good
morning yoda good morning david good
morning caitlin good morning lisa good
morning mj good morning robin everyone
is here
everyone is here the [ __ ] army is
here the [ __ ] fam they
say thank you thank you for joining us
on let's talk the tony michaels podcast
well we got a show for you today
of course you know bonehead of the week
is in the second hour because we are
here every single weekday noon eastern
11 central now for two hours
and bonehead of the week is is in the
second hour gabe will be joining us for
bonehead i also have a uh
a special person popping in i don't know
we'll see we'll see what time
they pop in but we'll do the [ __ ] list
roundup
and then we'll see when our special
guest pops in
they want to talk about uh
the toilet flushing
problems at the trump white house
the clogging problems you know you gotta
get the plunger out for this
[ __ ]
uh they also want to talk about the jan
january 6 select committee updates and
then also maybe some
alabama gerrymandering that could
possibly be on their list as well that
could be on their list as well
we gotta pop in
so stay tuned for that
stay tuned for that
what is in the news today boy it's it's
going of course everyone's talking about
hillary clinton's emails
the two the two emails that had the
little the little mark on it it possibly
could have been questionable
you know
that we're on a private server something
like that
you know it's it's not it's not like i
mean really you know
she did some egregious things
i mean
[Music]
it's not like she
stole top secret documents
stored them in boxes hid them from
people possibly tore them up and [ __ ]
ate them she wasn't eating emails i
wonder i wonder if it's like a
you know maybe there's a commercial
there
a parody commercial there you know like
a
kibbles and bits type thing
i don't know maybe
he it sounded like this happened more
than once and and i would really like to
ask michael cohen i don't know if you
guys heard the omarosa story but omarosa
claims
that this [ __ ] fat bastard
tore up a document and ate a document in
a meeting with after michael cohen now i
i don't know
um what exact meeting that was i don't
know if maybe he wrote two checks to
stormy and he ate one of them and the
other one's the one they gave i don't
know
i would love to have these people on to
ask these questions michael stormy hell
i'd have grandpa poopy pants on here to
ask him these questions if i could
we had him on a couple weeks ago i mean
it was it was a parody of him but he was
on he was on
[Laughter]
we have we we have to we have to get out
of this [ __ ] timeline
it is just absolutely [ __ ]
batshit crazy
and we were we have to sit here and talk
about
we have to sit here and talk about
how dude tears up notes and eats notes
because he doesn't want people to know
what's on the notes
how in the [ __ ] is it have you ever have
you ever like been at a disc or your
office or even like like and i don't
know just you wrote something down
someone wrote something down someone
handed you a document maybe you got an
important document mailed to you
and you're like i don't want this
document anymore
you know maybe it's a piece of junk mail
you throw it in the trash
this [ __ ]
is thinking in his brain i need to eat
this son of a [ __ ] now it goes way
beyond that
way beyond that
because i guess there's just some
documents you don't eat or you're full
right you're full you you you've eight
like you've ate like 12 boxes
of [ __ ] top secret documents
that are gonna [ __ ] convict you for
inciting a violent insurrection and
sedition conspiracy
and possible treason you ate like two
boxes of those top secret documents
you're full you're [ __ ] stuffed
you're not hungry anymore
you already had your [ __ ] top secret
snack right
you just you just can't eat anymore
so then what do you do well i mean you
can't run them through the paper
shredder because obviously the paper
shredder they'll be able to tape those
son of a [ __ ] back together everyone
has seen the movies
you know if you run it through a paper
shredder you just that's not safe enough
you either have to eat them and [ __ ]
them
into the toilet and flush them or oh
there you go maybe we'll flush them
maybe we'll flush them the problem is
these days
these days toilets just don't flush
documents like they used to
you know what i mean
i mean it used to be you could stuff you
know whole file folders full of
documents in the [ __ ] toilet
and just start hammering the
the handle and bam
they'd be flushed flushed flush you
could get rid you could get rid of 15
boxes worth of documents
with a good [ __ ] toilet
i mean i'm just saying
after you're full of course you know you
got to eat the important ones but once
you get full and you can't eat anymore
then you have to start what in the [ __ ]
are we doing
what the [ __ ] are we doing
what is it that we're doing here
and we were worried we were worried for
years like we had like 11 [ __ ]
11
[ __ ]
millions of dollars on benghazi
and then we went round and round and ran
and we're still talking about a couple
[ __ ] emails
that the email lady sent
we're still talking about it
this morning this morning i'm still with
her is trending
this is [ __ ] we're in february of
2022.
joe biden has been the president for
longer than a year
after four years of the [ __ ] paper
shredder
and we're and we're still we're still
hashing out if you if you're going to be
like oh well yeah maybe it was stupid to
do the whole email thing with hillary
we're still doing that
they're still talking about it on fox
news jesus [ __ ] christ you
[ __ ]
he was eaten he was eating [ __ ] top
secret notes dudes that's what he was
doing he was flushing the [ __ ] down the
[ __ ] toilet
because he was stuffed full
he already had three boxes of documents
he couldn't eat no more so he had to
start flushing them
are you [ __ ] listening out there
pluck your head out of your [ __ ]
asses
pluck it out of your ass these are the
people who are like oh
no mandates
no mandates we're gonna go to civil war
for mandates did you see this [ __ ]
video with ricky schroeder
someone someone quoted underneath the
[ __ ] video i don't know if it was in
the thread that i posted or if it wasn't
patriotic they said
they said i thought someone arrested the
una bomber
oh my god this [ __ ] guy
these people man this q anon religion
[ __ ] this this cult trump cult [ __ ] has
leaked into their [ __ ] brains
oh my god
listen
he was eating
top
secret documents he was stealing him and
taking him down to mar-a-lago
so he could either sell what was on him
or he could destroy him or maybe he just
wanted to keep him as souvenirs of
crimes he committed
i don't know i don't know what it is at
this point
but we freaked the [ __ ] out
freaked out because hillary clinton had
two emails that had a little [ __ ]
classification on it
we freaked the [ __ ] out freaked the [ __ ]
out
still freaking the [ __ ] out
do you guys remember a uh a general name
general michael petraeus i think it's
his name petraeus remember that do you
remember that story and he's a war hero
he helped us you know not get out of a
war in the middle east i don't know
everyone holds him up on high right he's
this great general
whatever
he got federally indicted do you
remember what that was
do you remember
remember what he got federally indicted
for
he was doing a book
and the the the
the woman who was writing his book they
ended up having a love affair
and he not only showed her the documents
but he let her have them in her position
when she shouldn't have them
right so he was illegally distributing
those documents and
giving those documents in a way
that was not a way that you give top
secret documents
now as we know the facts are that
donald trump is a [ __ ] criminal
and he committed crimes while he was
president so why shouldn't we assume
that the top secret documents that were
taken in boxes down to mar-a-lago along
with the [ __ ] letters with kim
jong-un and the [ __ ]
the hurricane poster board with the
sharpie on it
why shouldn't we believe that this has
to do with crimes that he committed
during
while he was president now the other day
i kind of you know i kind of breezed
over this like the presidential records
act because really honestly the
presidential records act
and i hope that our pop in today can can
give us a little more a little more
sense of
how severe the presidential record act
is but really it seems like it's almost
like the hatch act i mean yeah it's a
law and yeah they can punish you but
it's not [ __ ]
you know they're not gonna slam you in
prison now top secret documents
that's a whole nother [ __ ] ball game
[ __ ]
top secret documents mishandling top
secret documents that's a serious
[ __ ] crime
that's a serious [ __ ] crime
especially if what your intent is with
those documents
serious
serious [ __ ] that's not even that
didn't even have anything to do with the
presidential records act like that's not
even in the same [ __ ] universe right
i mean we were saying presidential
records act
nope
we we can't we can't go to attend with
these [ __ ] me and gabe went
over this
yesterday
he's trying to do a sketch about these
[ __ ] documents and these boxes of
documents
and and as the story develops day by day
by day gets worse and worse and worse
and more [ __ ] clownish and more
[ __ ] clownish and more unbelievable
and really honestly we should expect
this at this point and really when we
start to see some of these stories come
from the january 6 select committee we
should not be surprised when we're like
what in the [ __ ] were they trying to do
what a bunch of dumb [ __ ] we
should not be surprised when that
happens that's gonna happen we're gonna
hear stories that they thought [ __ ] that
was not even in the same goddamn realm
of [ __ ] reality that we all live in
these people
these people are still down in dallas
waiting for jfk junior to show up to run
with him in 2024 so he can become king
got it
we have a [ __ ] mental health problem
in this country bad really [ __ ] bad
and if you watch the video of ricky
schroeder you'll know that this q anon
[ __ ] this christian q anon [ __ ] trump
cult [ __ ]
is really a [ __ ] disease and it's
really [ __ ] it's leaking into the
minds of these these weak these weak
[ __ ]
and honestly we have a mental health
problem in this country and it is very
very very clear that we do
not to diminish mental health we need to
[ __ ] we need mental health health
care in this country fast stat right now
like quick fast and in a [ __ ] hurry
these people are being propagated into
[ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ]
and we'll get to it in the shitless
roundup
when i play you the [ __ ] ricky
schroeder video because jason bateman is
um
is trending this morning jason bateman's
trending because
uh him and ricky schroeder were in
silver spoons together i think just
before my time i don't remember i don't
remember [ __ ] i don't remember
[ __ ] silver spoons i don't know
the first time i remember jason bateman
is in teen wolf two this first time i
remember i don't know who the [ __ ] ricky
schroeder is
don't i mean other than he's a [ __ ]
whack-a-doo and he used to be a child
actor that's all i know about that
[ __ ]
and he loves kyle rittenhouse he loves
him some written house
because he shot and killed libtards or
some [ __ ]
you know these these [ __ ] people
these [ __ ] people are out of their
[ __ ] minds they lost it
actually their minds may have [ __ ]
walked away like up that's enough we're
taking our marbles and we're [ __ ]
going [ __ ] it
hell
what else do we have on the the agenda
today
for
the [ __ ] list roundup
uh we have uh
um of course i'm still with here afghan
there's some afghan news hipaa's
trending i have no idea why i have no
idea why
it but it's got to be something [ __ ]
stupid i'm sure
lester holt is trending um because
apparently biden didn't call him a son
of a [ __ ]
he used lighter words
ducey might be jealous i don't know
state of emergency is trending and then
kathy griffin is trending because of
um they're comparing a political ad for
some [ __ ] gq peer some psycho with a
gun making [ __ ] political ads talking
about killing their political opponents
yeah that's a thing that's happening and
they're comparing it to kathy griffin
this is the thing that we have to do we
[ __ ] lost our minds about an email we
lost our minds about a [ __ ] kathy
griffin picture
and here we are at a level [ __ ] 30
and it's gonna get worse
oh this 2022 election is gonna be worse
and worse and worse and worse
it's not gonna get better until i mean
it's not getting better
until after it gets worse
[ __ ] who had on their bingo card the
grandpa poopy pants was snacking on
documents and flushing them down the
toilet
who had that on their who who i [ __ ] i
didn't even
couldn't even tell you
that that was even
in the realm of possibility but here we
are
here we are
[ __ ]
should we start the [ __ ] list round up
let's go ahead and start the [ __ ] list
roundup
i guess this [ __ ] list is gonna need
some top secret toilet paper let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to
the shitless roundup where we round up
all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of today we've already been
talking about them
but we're going to go through them here
[Music]
see again i got it all messed up already
it's friday it's friday i'm ready for
the weekend who else is ready for the
weekend
uh here's some here's some [ __ ] that
gabe posted at this point nothing
surprises me this is this is more this
[ __ ] boneheaded type [ __ ] more of it
just
like i said it's just gonna be a [ __ ]
onslaught of just dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] look
at this stupid ass
hottest woman in congress award
i mean it's [ __ ] it's spelled wrong
here or at least it looks like it
[Laughter]
i don't know if this is real or not is
this real this is [ __ ] real
this can't be [ __ ] real that she's
proud of this thing right
it can't be
it can't be real no [ __ ] way is this
real
can't be
does that look real to you
hottest woman
lauren bobert holding up hottest woman
award their certificate expelled her
name incorrectly and came with the red
lobster gift card what the [ __ ]
okay
oh so god we just we can't
you can't you couldn't even you couldn't
even [ __ ] do this on saturday live
you couldn't you couldn't make this
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
like even even when you're standing
around trying to [ __ ] figure out what
would be funny here i'll make this
bigger so you can see the [ __ ] what
would be funny
what would be hilarious what would be
funny as [ __ ] well i mean i mean it
would be cool
if she like had a red lobster gift card
if she got a red lobster gift card
you know like i don't know 10 bucks you
know maybe she could get the uh
the chicken caesar salad or something
you know
i don't know maybe 25 bucks so she can
buy some lobster or some shrimp
hottest woman in congress what the [ __ ]
does that have to do why do you give a
[ __ ] red lobster gift guard without
this has got to be a [ __ ] joke this
can't be [ __ ] real patriotics is this
real
is this real
can't be
it we're just it's just so [ __ ] up
i'm just so [ __ ] up
oh no there's a goddamn up i'm not even
gonna tweet this look at this
look at this [ __ ]
i'm look wait wait for it
what the [ __ ] is going on
what in the f let's listen joining me
now
the first winner of the jessie kelly
show hottest woman in congress list
congress oh [ __ ] me
oh this is
jessie kelly is giving her the hottest
the first very first hottest woman in
congress where are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
this woman from colorado lauren bobert
congresswoman first and foremost before
we get to all the news of the day i want
to congratulate you on such a high
achievement and hope you got our satin i
see you did get our certificate and i
want to make sure you also got the gift
card we sent along with it
i got it
look at that jesse how's that
i are you i i i don't even i don't even
know how the [ __ ] i don't know how the
[ __ ] you make this funnier i have no
[ __ ] idea i have no idea i don't even
know if this is funny like we are wait
listen parody's funeral is next week's
friday next week friday parody we put
them in the ground for good they passed
away a long time ago we're finally gonna
bury parody um and maybe maybe maybe
their cousin satire with them um they're
also dead um we just haven't had the
funeral yet we're still just still
debating rather we have open casket or
we [ __ ] cremate him what in the
actual [ __ ] is going on
what the [ __ ] is this i'm not even gonna
finish watching this
oh my
oh [ __ ]
patriot takes
oh
you do a service by by showing us this
ridiculous [ __ ]
how do you even manage to get up in the
morning and
do this stuff it's [ __ ] so crazy
oh
whoosh
does any anyone else to anyone else can
you can you figure out what the [ __ ] is
going on
all right moving right along
oh jesus uh midas touch tweeted some
news uh texas state adjourn attorney
general ken paxton who you know is under
indictments for several
crimes he's he's a he's a known he's a
known indicted criminal is now suing the
bite administration for raising the
minimum wage on federal contractors
he's going to sue the government
he's
he's going to sue the federal government
right he's going to sue the federal
government for the federal government
raging raising wages that they pay to
their employees their contractors
you follow that
the dude in texas who is under criminal
indictment
is going to sue the government the
federal government
who has decided to raise their minimum
wage for their
for the people who contract with them
he's gonna sue him in texas
you follow
are you following me
democrats are fighting to increase wages
republicans are suing
to make them to make sure you stay poor
how in the [ __ ] can't we message
you want to know how we message
republicans want you to be poor
they want you to be poor
democrats deliver
federal minimum wages to contractors
republicans like texas attorney general
criminal
texas attorney general ken paxton want
to destroy your paycheck
got it
got it you follow me democrats deliver
republicans destroy this is a [ __ ]
prime example
priming oh jesus
source labels oh this is a prime example
right here
democrats deliver republicans destroy
joe biden wrote an executive order to
make sure to raise the minimum wage for
federal contractors ken paxton is going
to sue the federal government
to make sure that you don't get paid if
you're a federal contractor
there you go
democrats deliver republicans try to
destroy
that's it
what more do you what more proof do you
need there it is
mayo says good morning to everyone who
hasn't stolen top secret documents from
the united states
well good morning to you too and all of
all the rest of you out there that have
not stolen
top secret documents
i said how the [ __ ] couldn't you be
still with her
jesus christ how is this [ __ ] even a
thing
that you're that you're
somehow you're not with her at this
point what it's number one number one we
we have uh we have four years of proof
that she was correct
she was correct she was right
she was [ __ ] right the email lady was
spot on the whole time
spot on
oh [ __ ]
oh i was on uh dig on america it's it's
a another podcast um i was on there with
ray reid ray is running for congress in
missouri missouri's second for the
midterms
i had had a good discussion with ray and
uh had fun with the guys so go over and
go over and watch them
watch that episode it's on youtube
here's the link it's on it's on the
timeline
oh oh here here this is a good one this
is a good one i like this one
this is more joe rogan stuff let's talk
more about joe rogan shall we
[ __ ] okay
joe rogan
and tifa cabal president
okay so what's happening here well let's
go back let's go back let's get some
context here brett my zealous you guys
know
that the my zealous brothers
have been accused of being uh the head
of a
of
a of a
a secret cabal that's trying to take
down joe rogan
and and this whoever this urban guy is
posted this in a thread it's got 1.5
million views i don't know who it's from
i don't know if it's actually posted by
joe rogan or not but we'll find that out
here
we'll do our own research right here on
live on there
brett says is this supposed to make me
upset i've never advocated for joe to be
canceled despite the right wing fever
dream
i simply thought his comments were very
ugly and he agrees he said it in his
apology all this proves is that no one
is attacking him because of his politics
which destroys your argument it's
exactly joe rogan first off
joe rogan let's go to this [ __ ] video
here actually you know what let's
do let's give brett some credit
you read it you get credit right here on
the [ __ ] list roundup
but this guy post this and then in the
thread
proof rogan is right wing of course you
know he's like wink
wink
wink
now here's here oh this is uh this is a
guy uh breaking points with crystal ball
you ever seen this show these [ __ ]
idiots these [ __ ] idiots pretend to
be left wingers and [ __ ] oh well we're
just
we're non-biased we're non-biased
so here's joe rogan now listen to this
clip listen to what he says and now i'm
gonna give i'm gonna give the commentary
afterwards
i'm not gonna play the whole thing
because it's just the same [ __ ] over and
over but but let's listen to a little
bit of this and then i'll commentate i
really believe that michelle obama runs
she wins she's good she's great she's
the wife of the best president that
we've had in our lifetime i've never
voted right wing in my life i consider
universal basic income a really good
idea i want free college education take
it easy hello bernie how are you joe
wonderful pleasure to meet you nice to
meet you i like tulsi and i like bernie
that's it oh yeah everybody else can eat
[ __ ] look at you [ __ ] progressive
yeah i think i'll probably vote for
bernie i think he's looking out for the
interests of the working people and i
think he wants people to have a better
life and do better and i'm all for that
and if that means i have to pay more
intact like people think oh you're a
socialist i've heard people say that oh
you're [ __ ] socialist bro like first
of all he's not even a socialist he's a
democratic socialist it's a different
thing i would like to spend more in
taxes if they could fix inner city
communities and and take these poor okay
that's enough that's enough
you get the idea you get the idea right
that joe rogan has said the n word over
and over and over again he said racist
[ __ ] on his podcast over and over and
over again and then on the other hand he
said a lot of left-wing progressive
liberal socialist type stuff you know to
please us libtards look joe rogan joe
rogan has no politics got it
it that doesn't [ __ ] matter it
doesn't matter if you have politics or
not if your politics are left-wing and
you go on your show
and and you use the n-word
over and over and over again and and you
and especially if you use it in a
certain way or you tell a story about
how you went to the planet of the apes
you're probably gonna get [ __ ]
roasted right you're probably gonna get
[ __ ] roasted
the point here is that joe rogan doesn't
have politics and joe rogan hides behind
his [ __ ] comedy and he does this [ __ ]
on his show here's what he does here's
what he does whoever his guest is that's
who he is did you notice that he wasn't
in an argument with someone
he didn't get in an argument with
someone because when he has a guest on
his show he is whatever they are and
there's a reason for that
there's a reason for that
joe rogan sells advertising
okay he sells advertising
and joe rogan creates content
and when he's creating his content he
goes you know what when i have bernie
sanders on
when i have bernie sanders on i i bet a
million bucks that bernie sanders
supporters are gonna watch that episode
that's what he does
andrew yang when he has andrew gang on
he's betting money that people who like
andrew yang are gonna watch that episode
and guess what they're gonna do
they might watch a few more and they
might watch a few more here and a few
more there
joe rogan does all kinds of different
[ __ ] content he does ufc he has
comedians on he has politicians on he
has this wellness [ __ ] that he does
most people most people when they watch
rogan a lot of them will only watch one
type of content that he does
he knows that
spotify knows that
the point is
is when he was making racist [ __ ]
jokes he was telling it to a certain
[ __ ] audience
when he says uh oh i i like bernie and
bernie's and i'm not a socialist
bernie's not associate he's a democratic
so there's a difference
he knows who's listening
he's not [ __ ] dumb
and then he hides behind the guise of
comedy when he needs to
because he's not doing comedy when he's
doing his podcast it's not comedy that's
not comedy he is a comedian doing
commentary and he's having conversations
with people and when he has
conversations with people he reflects
who they are
in the conversation
because he doesn't want to have this big
heated conversation with someone in
front of him
that's not what he wants to do he didn't
want to challenge someone
it's very tough to challenge someone
especially when you have no political
[ __ ] beliefs
he doesn't he's not in politics he's a
clown
if you if you asked him a lot of his
opinions about ufc i'm sure you would
get it i'm sure you'd get it i'm sure
you get all kinds of opinions about ufc
the league the fighters
the rules
on and on and on and on it could
but when he even says into a microphone
in this clip
that bernie sanders uh you know oh
you're like bernie your associates well
bernie's not a socialist he's a
democratic socialist it's different
why mean socialist democratic socialists
yeah they're different but they're both
socialist dude
and if you knew if you knew a half a
[ __ ] thing about politics you would
know that
joe rogan doesn't know how bills are
passed joe rogan doesn't know how the
senate works joe rogan doesn't know how
the [ __ ] house works joe rogan
doesn't know how gerrymandering works
joe rogan doesn't know how state state
governments are different than the
federal government how they're
structured different in their
constitution
joe rogan probably doesn't know that
some states legislate every single year
some states legislate every other year
he doesn't probably know that
he has no clue unless unless the person
who he's interviewing who's sitting in
front of him says [ __ ] like that then he
yeah
yeah uh-huh right right yep that's right
that i agree i agree i agree and i agree
and then the next [ __ ] who's the
opposite opinion comes on yeah yeah
there's validity in that of course of
course there's validity in what you're
saying mr dumbass
and that's why he went down this road to
this anti-vaccine and and this coveted
[ __ ]
because it was profitable to have those
dumb [ __ ] on his show
and because it was profitable
to have those dumb [ __ ] on his
show he said what they wanted to hear
and by they i mean their audience
this is not about joe rogan this is not
about spotify it's not it's about the
audience
it's about the audience
that listens to joe rogan spotify knows
that spotify spotify doesn't give a [ __ ]
about joe rogan specifically and i've
said this before and i'll say it again
it could be whomever in a [ __ ] meat
suit doing what joe rogan's doing
as long as they bring the audience so
they can sell the advertising to the
audience
that's what it's about
that's what it's about
so there's your there's your joe rogan
[ __ ] of the day where joe rogan's a
white right winger and oh this video
proves this video proves that he's a
left-wing bernie socialist radical
libtard or whatever the [ __ ] that this
whatever the hell is trying to happen
here of course i said joe rogan the
antifa cabal president
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
oh caitlyn had a good one here
kaelin
madison cawthorne of course i'm going to
say his tweet sucks your tweet sucks bro
your tweet sucks man
three lettered agencies put america last
you know they're they're all on this
nazi american first [ __ ] you know they
can't help it uh bad company says here
you scared bro
thanks for your tweet thanks for your
tweet
of course kaelin always with the gifts
always
but let's let's go back um kalyn points
up points out rightly oh correct gop nra
fox kkk
the former guy
marjorie taylor green i mean there's you
know the list goes on and on and on and
on and on and on and on and on
thank you caitlyn for your tweet get get
him get that [ __ ] madison
cawthorn some people i don't call him
this but i've heard people call him
settler
i've heard this before where people call
him hitler
oh rachel bitkoffer you guys know rachel
one of our faves here on the tony
michaels podcast i'm sure we'll have her
in on monday
um you know monday is usually the rachel
poppin day
um she says you might be a fascist wait
yep you're a fascist
remember the trump card
do you remember the trump card with the
with the eagle we can't let these
[ __ ] forget this [ __ ] you know
there's so much [ __ ] there's so much
stuff that piles up you know that we
have to flush down the toilet
um that we we forget these things but
look at this this was a real thing this
donald trump card and you paid him to
get this membership card or some [ __ ]
but it has an eerie uh look that that
resembles you know whatever this is on
this side you might be a fascist yep
yep you're a [ __ ] fascist thank you
thanks rachel
thanks for the art strike pack
um if you want you can go over to
rachel's page and they've got a lot of
good gifts and some other memes you can
spread around too it's on that democrat
delivers
republicans destroy messaging um joe
here this is this is this is one of the
best
one of the best
toilet paper shredder jokes
of the day yesterday roto-rooter if
you're listening i hope you're able to
find
the 30 000 plus documents that are
missing oh my god
oh thank you for your tweet that one
that one had me rolling thank you joe
okay
now here's some more strike back rachel
um a presidential paper shredder
of course we can't help but pay
attention to that he was flushing
documents and needing documents and then
[ __ ] them out and flushing those
and we [ __ ] really missed we really
missed the point of the whole thing he
was stealing top secrets
like he was doing the [ __ ] on a level of
a thousand million gazillion of what
hillary clinton did with the two emails
that they found on her private server
he was sticking top secret emails and
private boxes and then he was probably
wiping them you know he was wiping them
clean i don't know you remember that
[ __ ] okay um gabe says here in march
2011 senator rand paul addressed the u.s
department of energy official about his
broken toilets uh oh
how long have republicans been flushing
documents down the toilet let's see
frankly my toilets don't work in my
house
and i blame you and people like you who
want to tell me what i can install in my
house what i can do
you restrict my choices
we don't even save money we flush them
ten times they don't work
[Laughter]
they they literally like they get a
catchphrase right and this is the [ __ ]
that we don't do good enough like they
get a [ __ ] catchphrase and they say
that [ __ ] and they say that [ __ ] and
they say that [ __ ] and they say that
[ __ ] and they say that [ __ ] and it
always turns out to be [ __ ]
projection doesn't it always
always god damn
god damn rand paul
somebody call rand paul's neighbor his
toilet is running that that day okay
let's go to tweet tweets and trendy
trends we're about to get our guest here
and i haven't even got to the damn to
the damn tweety tweets and the trendy
trends here uh afghan is is trending
apparently the reason why is because
president biden is expected to issue an
executive order
to move some seven billion of the afghan
central bank's assets frozen
in the u.s banking system to fund him
humanitarian relief in afghanistan and
compensate september 11 victims holy
[ __ ] you mean you mean he's gonna make
sure that that the money goes to where
the money should go ah that [ __ ]
i'm sure they'll spin this [ __ ] around
oh
brandon look at brandon making sure that
the people
the making sure that the people who need
humanitarian aid rather be in
afghanistan or the 911 victims here uh
how dare he that son of a [ __ ] i'm sure
that's what it'll i don't know i don't
know how they'll spin this one and he'll
be evil for this
you'll see he'll be evil it'll be oh
it'll be egregious
and he's giving 911 victims money you
son of a [ __ ] okay hip is trending
number eight
um
it's it's hipaa not hip hip oh i see
what what how it's trending it's
training with two p's
if you're gonna get the law wrong at
least get the name right
who the [ __ ] is tweeting this [ __ ] then
it's come on
what the hell
what the hell
they lost my connection something went
wrong it's not my
fault twitter is twitter's broken
twitter's broken
it won't let me retweet no we're in
trouble here we're in trouble oh my god
okay we're just gonna have to view
there's no retweeting there's no
commenting apparently let's let's let's
reload here maybe something
maybe we'll try it we'll try let's see
nope nope
tweet again in a minute you see this
down here in the bottom you see this
here let's let's let's move this
twitter's broken
or at least my twitter's broken see i'm
trying it and tristan here is getting
let's
like see down here something went wrong
try liking your tweet again in a minute
i don't know
i know maybe they banned me
maybe maybe they've turned me off
already
they possibly
banned my account maybe i made ricky
schroeder mad speaking of that let's go
back to the trends uh [ __ ] the hippa
thing for now let's go back to the jason
bateman oh because i want to watch this
video
i want to watch this video this [ __ ]
idiot patriot takes post to this video
former silver spoons child child actor
ricky schroeder
hopes our truckers quote unquote will
shut down dc and shut down sacramento
shut down albany shut down all these
states shut down the capital to root out
this evil so he wants he wants truckers
in this country to commit a coup
like these people like like they have
like [ __ ] wet dreams over coos like
they're like yeah [ __ ] overturn the
government baby let's overturn the
government let's do that let's overturn
the government
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about what are you [ __ ] talking about
ricky
the truckers are gonna [ __ ] overturn
the government listen to this stupid
[ __ ] this blithering idiot
i think we see what we're facing here
it's an evil
um
that is trying to be forced upon our
children and upon us and
god bless the canadian truckers
and the canadian cowboys up there on the
border
and i heard a great
potential uh
event going to happen for us with our
truckers
are gonna what the [ __ ] is a great
potential event what are you talking
about
what the [ __ ] are you are you talking
about like another insurrection buddy
because it sounds like that's what
you're saying let's hear maybe
start mobilizing mobilizing yeah like
planning like conspiracy committee can
you see what we need to do doing what we
need to shut down washington oh you mean
like a seditious conspiracy
these people just can't stop they can't
stop cooing what the [ __ ] are you doing
he shut down sacramento sacramento
albany so they want they just want to
shut down governments like they're like
nope no more california state government
no more new york state government no
more federal government we're going to
coo them all we're going to we're going
to go down this we've been going to the
school boards and committing coups we're
gonna go to your town council commit
coups
what the [ __ ] are you doing are you
gonna take over the 4-h clubs too buddy
jesus [ __ ] crisis people shut down
these states and these this capital
shut down these states in this case
listen listen here's what he's saying
here's what he's saying you know he's
mad about you know he's mad about he's
mad about shutdowns he's bad about
mandates he's mad about mask so you know
what his answer is shut him down oh you
were we're tired of shutdowns so we're
gonna shut you down
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about you people have lost your goddamn
minds
ricky ricky
get away from the [ __ ] fire dude
you're you're highly flammable at this
point out this evil
it was almost perpetrated upon us
we were so asleep
but um here we go we do have to root
this out we can't just turn the blind
eye to it these people must be held
accountable yeah for what they've
attempted to do
and um
or there'll be no peace yeah
you want war we get that you want war
you want insurrection you want to
overturn governments you want a coup you
want to coo them all coup all the
governments if it looks like government
smells like government coup that son of
a [ __ ] we got it justice
so
god bless united states yeah
god bless all of you who are fighting
and resisting right
god bless those who are waking up whoa
did you hear that god bless those who
are waking up ricky schroeder has come
over to the woke side these [ __ ]
idiots
these [ __ ] idiots these
brain dead [ __ ]
uh the woke mob the woke mobs coming
after you that's all the mandates are is
the woke mob and it's all wokeness
you're you're woke
oh we gotta wake up
we gotta wake up and i'm so god bless
all those who are awoke
you [ __ ] idiots
here's what this guy's doing he's just
using all the catchphrases that he can
slam into two minutes here or a minute
and a half whatever the [ __ ] this is all
the [ __ ] little catchphrases that are
gonna get his little thousands of people
to go [ __ ] donate to him right
he's going to slam him in there the god
bless the cooing the overturning the
government's bad [ __ ]
you know we got to take over there
there's a atrocities that have been done
against us and the world's coming to an
end and hey ricky throw the bible into
the [ __ ] fire dumbass stop reading
that [ __ ] book it's got you all
twisted up and turned around you dumb
[ __ ] when's the last time you had a
[ __ ] movie roll jesus christ i'm not
even going to watch the rest of it i'm
not not going to do it let's see if it's
let's see if twitter's working it's not
twitter's not working
everyone else is saying mine's okay in
vegas damn you robin
mine's down in california david says
looks like twitter's having some [ __ ]
problems looks like twitter's having
some problems let's let's reload and see
what we can do
and yeah this is yeah we do the [ __ ]
list roundup here but yep see look it's
[ __ ] it's gone
it's gone there there there's that
there's that one
well as we as we try to fix the the the
twitter problems i think we have oh yeah
we do
we have we have a a special pop in here
so let's let's go let's go to the po poc
poppin
mr popock how are you
the po pog poppin i feel like the poppin
fresh kid from
pillsbury doughboy
oh oh okay you know
yeah
how are you it's been it's been a minute
it's been a minute but i'm glad you're
back wait a minute can you hear me how's
my mic you're always adjusting my mic
for me how's it today no no no it's it's
perfect it's perfect i see i see you're
sitting in a position though where there
is no controversy of rather that
painting is crooked i can't i can't tell
you how much um
ink has been taken up
with the question of whether that blue
painting behind me when i sit at my desk
and i do the podcast for legal af is
crooked i get all these compliments
about the show great show tonight i
really like the show i love the
camaraderie between you and ben myself
but that painting is driving me crazy
i get it with this one here i get it see
how this kind of looks
it's it's not crooked i checked it but
but the camera makes it look crooked
because of you know
but but you know this is ali
did you see on my twitter feed that i
actually posted a picture of the
painting with a level on top of it with
the bubbles to show the first level
still still no one believes well you
know we we live we live in a skeptic
society today um the the craziest part
is is like what we're talking about just
before you came on is that people will
believe absolutely anything and really
we're in it we're primed we're primed
and ready to believe almost anything
because anything is possible when we
hear stories like i knew i did not have
the president united states ripping up
notes and eating them and then flushing
you know he was so full he ate four
boxes of top top secret documents that
he had to start flushing them down a
toilet i i can't even tell you like we
are in such a weird timeline but but but
i know you can probably speak to
what the legality of this is because
last week we were talking about the
presidential records act right because
he may have taken stuff that he
shouldn't have that belonged to the
office of the president but now it's
switched a little bit
because now we're talking about
did he or did he not take top secret
documents because that's a whole nother
realm of legality and what it means when
you're talking about
taking documents whether it's the
presidential records act or this top
secret thing
and when it was when it was hillary
clinton and everybody was all upset that
she had a private email server in the
basement of chappaqua long island house
by the way
many many politicians have their own
servers the only the question there is a
nuance of public records law
and what what has to be secured she
didn't destroy anything it wasn't not
available to the national archive it
just happened for a time to be stored
because she was switching between you
know hillary.gov and hillary personal
and that things happened i'll tell you
what she didn't do she didn't take 12
boxes of documents marked top secret
with her and imagine to get to 12 boxes
tony
as the president and his people you got
to go through hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of boxes and
pieces of material and go these are the
12 that i want to take with you to
mar-a-lago
those are the hot 12.
you know
what do you think do you think he was
like collecting them throughout the four
years and he's like i'm definitely gonna
take i'm definitely gonna take these at
the end
outside do you think like it was a mad
dash at the end
when they make the tv movie about it it
will be what you just said which is he's
oh this box is definitely coming with me
tomorrow
right but i don't in the real world of
of trump and his lunacy and his madness
i just think at the end you know
somebody knocked on the door and said mr
president yes so we've identified
another box that you probably would like
to take with you to mar-a-lago oh what's
in that box
what's in my box i want an inventory
it's the greatest box in the world i
love this right right right okay that
box is definitely going give it to
melanie you could just see the whole by
the way that's about as close to trump
as i'm gonna get okay okay i don't do a
good trump either so it's okay yeah
that's that's mine is sort of like alec
baldwin doing trump doing whatever but
okay um no i think that's how it went
and and the fact that he actually
highlighted how how important it was to
him that these documents not end up in
the national archive and not see the
light of day with the jan sex committee
ultimately because he knew going out
there was going to be a big problem so
he took these with him now
national archive has gone one step
further than they went with hillary
clinton
which is they think there's a possible
criminal
um
criminal obstruction criminal
violation of the records laws
and has made a referral to the
department of justice and the department
of justice merrick garland is going to
open up a uh investigative file and
determine what's in the boxes
why were they taken i mean what's trump
gonna say i mean uh uh you have maggie
haber for the new york times who
apparently according to close confidants
of trump
that's the book that he's most worried
about not the
uh the uh you know the book bob woodward
wrote
you know a couple of books that bob
woodward wrote he's worried about maggie
haber because maggie haber an intrepid
new york times reporter for the last 20
or 30 years has been following trump
since like the day he bought the first
hotel with daddy's money
and and knows him better than anybody
else i mean there's actually a photo of
him with maggie haber maybe you can find
it while we're talking or put it up um
where he's got the you know it's got the
giant thumbs up or small thumbs up and
he's smiling with maggie haber in the
white house
she knows her [ __ ] she's an intrepid
investigative reporter this is where the
flushing the toilet came from an excerpt
from maggie haber he's worried about
more coming out of that book and so
um
he's worried about it he takes these
boxes with him
national archive says
i don't have everything i need to do to
turn over to the jan six committee
there's 12 boxes missing the interesting
thing and we have to get to the bottom
of is why did it take the the national
archive and the national archivist a
person why did it take them this long to
determine that there were boxes that
were missing
like what was what tipped them off to
that you know they don't sound like that
video of 12 boxes going out something
tipped them off now maybe the jan six
committee work tipped them off
uh about the missing boxes
well
that that that that's a really good
point and and again that's how the story
has evolved right like at first it was
he had the kim jong-un litters right and
he had and he had the the poster board
with the sharpie on it where he was
trying to convince people that no no no
this map really you remember sharpie or
w where you draw you mean you talk about
the hurricanes
he had that poster apparently in this in
this set of you know [ __ ] that he took
and he also had he also had the kim
jong-un letters which the story is is
that oh he's still talking to him and
he's still communicating with him you
know they still had this bromance going
on but so it's evolved into that but
it's evolved all the way down to this
guy's taking top secret documents and
not only that he's eating he's eating
he's eating documents and he's flushing
them down the toilet where where is the
eating flushing i know the flushing
where's the eating part so
who's reporting on that i'm omarosa and
and
i i would love to have michael cohen on
my show omarosa claims in her book
that she watched donald trump put
documents in his mouth notes from a
meeting that he had with michael cohen
he was she watched him eat these notes
i don't know
you know now i mean i guess i guess
if you're in a situation where you're in
a room and you're talking about
sensitive stuff and there's notes that
are going to prove that there's a crime
been committed possibly and the only way
to make sure that that document doesn't
see the light of day when you exit that
room is to rip it up and eat it i mean i
guess maybe that's your thought process
that's that's some crazy [ __ ] i'm not
listen uh i'm gonna believe maggie
habers reporting over amarosa
um she's got her own she has her own
credibility problems i think it's you
know he look he's mad as a hatter um
donald trump
i'm just not ready to buy into the um to
the eating and crapping part but from a
legal standpoint which is where legal af
comes in and we'll be talking about this
more on our weekend podcast that ben
misalis and i do uh live saturday nights
and
and drop the audio on sunday uh sunday
mornings we're going to talk about
you know the presidential records act
criminal prosecutions related to this
inter you know um obstruction of justice
and other counts that can be brought
against
against the president and and when he's
on the way out
he no longer enjoys immunity
so anything he did as citizen trump
with the moving trucks on the day out on
the day of or the switchover from the by
you know the trump administration at
1201 when biden takes the oath of office
he is now citizen trump and he doesn't
get immunity there's no there's no i've
been i was president five minutes ago
immunity defense for the 12 boxes he can
be prosecuted for that now um what will
he be we'll have to see but look the gen
6 committee is now
rapidly coming to a conclusion
of its work and it's i think in the next
month if not earlier they're going to be
doing televised hearings in which they
present
a lot of video and audio evidence and
documentary evidence on a powerpoint for
the american people led probably if i
had a guest by jamie raskin and a couple
of the other um you know really eloquent
legal scholars that are on the gen 6
committee
and um
yeah i think
i think there's there's going to be a
lot of offshoots coming off of that with
criminal referrals the department of
justice from the gen 6 committee one and
that's a good point because um
all the evidence are are the top secret
documents in these 15 boxes or whatever
it was that the national archives had to
go down and you know rummage through an
old dusty attic and a
beat-up golf club down in south florida
um the reason why the reason the reason
why that's significant is because those
documents are possibly in the hands of
the january 6th select committee and
and
whatever those documents are rather
there's criminal activity because this
guy's not going to stop criming
rather there's criminal activity of him
taking them but if there's criminal
activity inside those documents that's
the important thing that the january
sixth election yeah
yeah we have to guess it's not 12 boxes
of telephone books he picked these boxes
for a reason you know this could be the
mother lode you know back in the
watergate era which we talked about a
lot
when we talked about trump and what
happened to those
culprits
including attorney generals going to
jail uh you know mitchell went going to
jail during watergate you know there's
the famous story of the uh 18 missing
minutes
from uh audio tapes that nixon ran
you know there was an early rudimentary
recording system in the white house
which really there should still be now
and there there was 18 minutes missing
at a critical moment that would have um
that would have uh implicated uh nixon
you know and then you have people trying
to cover for him like his secretary who
said oh i accidentally erased it right
my foot my foot pedal
like you know
it happens right happens this is 12
boxes of material that he was trying to
delete that he's trying to delete
essentially it hasn't come out the
reporting yet but i got to believe that
jan6 committee tipped them off the
national archives because how would they
have known there were 12 boxes missing
you know when you get the inventory it's
not like you go hmm you know you're
doing the inventory and you're like
you sound like they had a checklist like
where's where's box six six through you
know 18 right where are they seem to be
missing somebody must have said boxes
went out the back door and how did they
get to 12. i really want to find out the
reporting here on how they who who
dropped a dime on trump and how how are
they so specific in their information
right well again you know it's probably
this is the most fantastic box ever and
i have to have this box you know that
that may have been you know because the
information inside would be
fantastically um the ability to probably
indict him for more crimes because i i
don't bla
like you're saying i don't believe he
took these boxes because he has some
kind of you know a connection to these
documents
he's taking these documents for a reason
have you ever seen pictures of trump
like in his office he's got like just
like stacks of of paper and it's a mess
it's a mess right it's a mess
and and you know that that's probably a
lot what this is is the big mess that
he's stuffing inside boxes because he's
like i have to keep these i have to keep
these because i i don't want anyone to
see this stuff and back to the uh
the deleting of the the nixon tapes the
other news that we had was that there
was deleting of phone records inside the
white house that they haven't found yet
of communications on the day of the
january 6 um the insurrection
the coup attempt and i think that's
going to be a significant thing when
they figure that out too um as well that
was clipped
well a couple of things one is to
correct ourselves it looks like it's 15
boxes that were taken yeah yeah um
yeah now by the way trump might have
actually you know somebody on his staff
might have found him at mar-a-lago and
said
uh
these aren't supposed to be here these
are radioactive they're supposed to go
back to the next right right right
because apparently they've already
recovered them and they've looked inside
of those boxes including the north
korean memorabilia that you talked about
but on the
missing phone logs i'm not sure that
that may not fall into the category of
the missing 18 minutes on the on the
nixon tapes that may just be that he
stayed off the phone
during critical moments and to and or
directed traffic in other ways so
they're gonna have to get us text
they're gonna have to get so so what
you're saying is is that there's not a
phone record but there's possibly a
record someplace else and that may be
where they find it would anybody be
surprised that he used the communication
device and didn't have it properly
logged does that does that surprise
anybody
i mean you know or he was doing it
through you know he's on his own
personal phone he gets rudy giuliani in
the war room or flynn in the war room at
the hotel across the street on the phone
and he says all right boys what's
happening okay green light or whatever
he says but it but again it hurts the
gen 6's ability to connect the dots
and and place trump
at the at the arranging and organizing
leading into jan six
um because now they're gonna have to
rely on the eyewitnesses like you know
melania's
uh pr person who said he was in the
dining room enjoying lunch
you know and being really happy about
watching everybody on television storm
the capitol
they may never get
all of the dots connected between
between the two of them but there's
there's such powerful
circumstantial which is not a bad thing
in the law people think oh it's
circumstantial most cases are proved
through circumstantial evidence but just
the overwhelming quantity and quality of
the circumstantial evidence leads to the
inference the legal inference
logical inference that that that night
followed day that the moon follows the
sun
you may not see it
you know but but you know it's there i
mean i i don't see the moon impacting
the tides
but i know they are right so right
we get all that together and that's what
the jan 6 committee is going to do even
if this is missing i don't want people
to think oh no they'll never be able to
connect trump to this there's missing
phone locks there's enough witness
testimony documented documentary
testimony from cooperating witnesses
even ones i believe who have gone on on
the media because they don't want to
risk the ire of trump and have said
we'll never cooperate over my dead body
bernie carrick you know uh mccallahan
whatever the press secretary's name is
uh the the woman that was um
yeah mac and ninny whatever her name is
they've all gone in and testified by the
way right right right and they and they
totally pled the fifth on all of it they
didn't say a word yeah right i don't
think so i mean even even stuart rhodes
from a jailhouse
cooperated with the jan six committee
and while he did assert the fifth
amendment where frankly he should have
because he is i mean
the likelihood of criminal prosecution
is beyond a likelihood he's being
criminally prosecuted so he shouldn't
have to testify against himself but
apparently because of his ego and
otherwise he decided there were some
things he could tell the gen 6 committee
so even stuart rhodes has you know
testified right well that's a good point
because
i interviewed
tasha adams his strange ex-wife and his
estranged son um and that interview is
on youtube and uh it's fascinating um
but when you go look at that six hours
of testimony the story is is that he he
didn't testify on anything from january
5th and january 6th so the lead up to
the insurrection which leads me to
believe that um possibly and the gen 6
committee was like yep sure but i want
to ask you as maybe a federal criminal
defense attorney
is that significant in the in the
criminal um indictment that he has that
that gen 6 wouldn't maybe want him to
actually um you know testify or say a
few things that would damage the
possibility of the federal prosecutors
bringing that indictment against him on
the conspiracy charges and possibly
roping more people into the conspiracy
because that's what happens with a
federal prosecution when they indict
conspiracy is there superseding
indictments with that conspiracy that
continue to draw in more fish as they
say you know little fish big fish stuff
to draw in more fish to this indictment
but do you think that had anything to do
with the gen 6 committee saying okay
we'll let you come in and and and
give your testimony but we will leave
out the january 5th january 6th
no
i don't think so and the reporting is
they left off the january 5th of january
so the reporting the reporting is that
that the select committee um they wanted
that of course but stewart rhodes and
his attorneys did not take the uh they
they waved
to actually give the january 5th and
january 6 testimony of those days well
they can't they can't he's facing
criminal prosecution right well and they
and they won't they it can in january
six but uh the select committee but in
the criminal prosecution there's no
waiving anything i mean it's a full-on
discovery right yeah so so there's
nothing that they can do there um i i
just wanted to know if there's
significance in that waving i don't
think so
okay no i i don't think so i think you
know i think the new york times did it
for people that are interested the new
york times about two weeks ago did a
very good double double centerfold um
walking through
you know the first 10 oath keepers the
next 10 oath keepers who's been indicted
for conspiracy who's been indicted for
obstruction and why and a timeline
starting three months you know really
like the day after the election leading
into jan you know two three four five
and then six and who did what you know
who who's the weapons officer you know
who brought in all the weapons and
stored them in the days in you know uh
for use you know who what did stuart
rhodes do and when when did the other
nine people that were indicted along
with him what did they do with him and
what did the others do and it's a very
good timeline date by date by date by
date so if i commend people to go look
at that if they're interested in seeing
why there's an indictment of these
people do you think do you think there's
a a conspiracy beyond the oath keepers
to
something maybe to this rolling stone
article that we've seen several months
ago where
members of congress possibly were
bartering with pardons
for people to act on behalf of trump and
kind of connecting with trump through
channels um to promise pardons whether
that was you know the pardons were
actually gonna happen or not because he
stood on stage a couple weeks ago and he
said yep i'm going to pardon anyone
january 6th oh yeah right so he so my
guess is maybe obstruction in another
which may be obstruction in and of
itself just him saying it into a
microphone
well and so so my guess my question is
is is do you think there's with that
reporting with the members of congress
can that conspiracy from what you've
read about the oath keepers can it
continue to again little fish big fish
stuff
yeah it could i think i i'm gonna i'm
gonna uh keep my powder dry
yeah until the giant sex committee comes
in not taking any bets is what you're
saying
yeah i mean look if there were evidence
i just don't like to deal too much in
the in the world of speculation i like
to be more you know
um
well
so i'd like to get the play-by-play
right you know that's a good point
though that the play by play because i
think that's a little bit of this drip
drip drip out of the select committee
and also what they'll try to orchestrate
through the um when they do the actual
public hearings is try to tell the story
of what happened on january 6th and what
happened with the insurrection and and
how this was a coordinated effort to
overthrow the constitution and our vote
um i think they'll they'll kind of work
that in a way uh to make sure that that
story is told but they're not gonna i'd
be shocked they're not gonna pull any
punches during the presentation right
they're going to put up on the screen
the claw thorns of the world and all the
other house members
and marjorie taylor green and all the
people if they have evidence that some
of them held the door open or gave them
a tour the day before
and let them do a little map making uh
as a blueprint for the uh insurrection
that's going to go up on the screen for
people to know this this uh legislator
did this the day before in giving a tour
to these people this person encouraged
it this way this person incited the riot
this way and they're going to
distinguish because you know this will
answer the stupid question asked by
ronald daniels with the rnc
which is the whole thing is just
legitimate political discourse
let's break it okay let's make let's
make it simple
the [ __ ] on the ellipse
of a rally
as distasteful as those that follow your
show and my show may find it is
legitimate first amendment expression
and political discourse right and i welc
and i welcome it i really want to live
in a country where jack booted you know
you know uh gazpachos
okay came down the mall i mean cold soup
cold soup police came down there yeah
yeah she's the only person in the
history of the world that made the nazis
sound delicious
so so we don't i don't want to live in a
jack-booted world where people suppress
first amendment expression so what
happened on the ellipse
proper legitimate political discourse
right the subgroup the subset of that
that were always as we know from the
proud boy investigation were always
there
to
uh wreak havoc
and try to overthrow the government and
the peaceful transfer of power they were
a subset of the group that was at the
ellipse some of them were at the ellipse
many of them skipped the speech making
at the ellipse and went directly to the
capital
right to commit
chaos well there's this big venn diagram
right like
what you're saying so so rhona daniels
is mcdaniels is
right only about
the the group and there were you know
frankly there were peaceful people at
the ellipse i may not agree with them
politically but i don't care if they're
there listening to who they thought was
their president that's fine the subset
of violent
anarchists
this is what they are they're heroes
they're not patriots they were
anarchists
that wanted to
overthrow the country and stop the
peaceful transfer of power and the will
and frustrate the will of the people
that armed and dangerous
that armed insurrection that's not
legitimate political discourse
well no i well i mean i mean the the day
of january 6 to to try and and
pin it up as all legitimate political
discourse even mitch mcconnell batted
that down quickly and my thought is is
that mitch mcconnell does not
as much as we do not like his politics
he does not use an unmeasured word at
all in front of a microphone and for him
to come out and basically say
support mike pence and saying that trump
is a loser and what he did is
un-american and by by doing that by
supporting that message you know through
the week um i i think they know stuff's
coming i think they know these public
hearings are not going to be good i
think i think they know
um
this news about
these documents as silly as some of it
may be
that it is real the oath keepers being
charged with seditious conspiracy is
real this is going to extend on
like you said you're going to have
members of congress being called out
right into these hearings um i believe
there could be even be a list of
expulsion um that is brought to the
floor because of some of this evidence
that is brought in today i agree with
these public hearings so
whether that's rather that's their
direct aim or not um i think that's a
possibility so i appreciate you joining
us bobox thanks thanks come back anytime
just send a message whenever you're
ready uh everyone stick around right
after this we're going to do bonehead of
the week you'll you'll love this pobag
the bone end of the week um this week
we've got we've got uh brian swaby we
got forrest gump kevin mccarthy did you
see him run run kevin run did you see
did you see that
i'll watch i'll follow up and watch your
show yeah and then jared kushner is also
on the list but we had some other people
that we had to add in like the uh the
soup nazi margaery taylor green so
everyone
go follow popock on twitter at ms popock
and go watch legal af this weekend it's
on saturdays on youtube live and then it
download you can download it on all your
your favorite directories on sundays
well we're on we we we're having fun
you're on there sometimes we do an 8 p.m
eastern time youtube live recording of
the podcast goes a couple hours you know
get get something comfortable go get a
six pack we go and i go through you know
eight to ten
cutting-edge this week legal and
political stories from supreme court you
know this week i know i know we're
talking about we're going to be talking
about the alabama decision on the voting
rights act and gerrymandering we're
going to talk about sarah palin's
lawsuit which is now in the first week
of trial for defamation against the new
york times here in in new york we're
going to talk about the first jan 6
trial
first criminal trial for the justice
department to show its stuff and shred
its stuff and put up all of its evidence
is going to be happening at the end of
february and uh
and we're and we're going to talk about
scotus and the and the decision that
scotus is that the biden
administration's gonna be making about
the next justice so we've got a lot to
talk about join us there and then we
drop it on you know
apple pod and spotify and all that on
sunday morning at midnight and then you
do also a wednesday show so catch that
as well yeah we're doing a wednesday
show half an hour wednesdays with
another co-anchor karen friedman
agnifilo who used to be in cybance's
manhattan da's office and we talked it
kind of leans a little bit more
prosecutorial but we
we do that a drill down uh every
wednesday also on all those channels for
30 minutes tony thanks for having me
thanks thank you sir and
everyone stick around we'll be back with
the bonehead after this thanks for
joining us pope bach
we'll see you soon
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us we're going
to do bone end of the week and
um i'm not sure what the hell's going on
but it looks like uh
my producer and co-host has become the
bonehead of the week i don't know what
the hell is going on but um gabe howard
how are you gabe what what's going on
over there what what
uh can can you hear me hi this is uh
this is twitter technical support oh
okay twitter are you there i i'm here
can you see me i i can see you yes okay
great great great yeah so uh we've been
experiencing some outages this morning i
just wanted to report uh i saw some
calls come in
and uh today i am your uh tech support
so
just wanted to make sure twitter was up
and running for you i know it was down
for some people but i want to make sure
that you know for twitter users uh we
are taking care of you
well good i'm glad you're with us
because we were having some trouble
earlier um and i think i think even the
hashtag twitterdown is is trending now
if on on the platform that is still
going uh we'll make sure to suppress
that right away do you
do you want me to pull that up so you
can see that search let's see that
sure sure they don't they don't let us
surf twitter at work so okay here here
is the uh twitter down um feed
oh yeah we're gonna have to bring this
one down yeah i might
request to suppress this right now yeah
okay well yeah yeah you might want to
you might want to say something about
the uh and then the hashtag if you're
wondering here is twitter
down that's happening i think it's
because because twitter's
not working i don't know what and what
regions of the twitterverse are not
working uh that is privileged
information oh okay i'm just here to
make sure i'm just here to make sure
that uh you're good to go and we do not
discuss the fact that twitter is down
but rather that twitter is up
yeah well twitter seems to be
up but the hashtag twitter down seems to
be
up as well i mean i'm just it's turning
at number three
okay
[Music]
yeah kill it kill it uh-huh
are you unplugging twitter are you what
i'm sorry what was that what are you
saying twitter sorry sir it looks like
there's a bad connection here um what
hey can you hear me hello hello can you
can you hear me over at twitter
yes i can hear you yes okay twitter down
is it seems to still be trending i don't
know if you turned it off or not
[ __ ] killer yeah it's it's it's at
number two now it's getting better like
it's it's moving up the
it's moving up
down up down
um yeah twitter is down no twitter no
twitter is down
um yep anyway uh just want to make sure
that you're good to go and twitter is
working for you sir uh
twitter is perfect i think i think we'll
be able to manage at this point we are
going to go to
bonehead of the week so let's start
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh welcome back to the show for bone
head of the week
hey gabe how are you whoa hey what's
going on just got out of the shower what
oh did you okay well that's that's good
that's good did you see did you see this
guy uh you come on the uh
come on the screen here well we had to
call twitter the there's twitter support
um that's that is crazy what are you
talking about well you know it you know
twitter was down earlier um it's
trending actually oh was it yeah i just
i just woke up i just got out of the
shower yeah yeah
trending number two twitter is down it
was down it actually went down while i
was on the show
wow some people still have
tweeted that that sucks that's yeah that
does
you know what you know what it really
sucks for when we do bonehead of the
week because we like rely on twitter
right to do the production
luckily uh whoever your support person
was
if i had to assume
they uh they came and they fixed
problems so now we're on twitter right
we're on we we have twitter for now oh
for now right now rather now how long it
would be up or down i guess is the
is the question um they were really
upset over there at twitter
um because the trend down was trending
up and they want to not have it down but
up right right you know you get you get
the yeah you want twitter up but they
don't want they want the trend down not
uh it's it's kind of confusing yeah i i
you know what if i had to assume i i'm
pretty sure there was some confusion
because they they've been testing the uh
down vote upvote
uh oh yeah you know so
i haven't seen that much is that is that
for us here or is this in different
regions that they have no we don't we
have it i've seen it around basically uh
you can downvote stuff so it's like you
know trying to be like reddit
right so can you download the downvote
can you do that no you can only downvote
comments
oh oh so it's not actually tweets
yeah yeah you can i mean well
technically they're all tweets tony you
know oh jesus you can down vote a
comment i don't think you can down vote
is it a comment or is it a reply because
it says reply it doesn't say okay fine
we'll call it a reply you know what
semantics okay i'm just saying i'm just
saying replies just trying to
call i mean we can call the tech support
guy back if we want sure yeah if you
want to call him up i'm sure he would
love to speak maybe we could maybe
he could call back we could ask him
comment reply comment reply well let's
let's get into bone of the week we're
we're 23 minutes into the second hour
right what do you think of our bone ends
this week oh good selection good
selection yeah we've got uh you know
misogynist brian salve
salve is that how he landed
i believe it's because he has an accent
over the e technically and i wasn't we
didn't put it here
right do you think do you think there's
actually an accent or you think he just
puts that on there
i bet he put it on there he's you know
he was like as a look at the guys look
at the guy's beard he definitely
definitely put it on there it's very you
know hipster pastor uh
i'll tell you what you should
do and do not do as a christian and then
you've got uh run kevin run
and i'm a porcelain doll jared kushner
right
yeah well so what what is the jared
because i know i know
um greg o'lear wrote the story about
jericho but what is the jared kushner
thing we'll start there and then we'll
we'll go to brian because i definitely
want to take a minute on brian um and
then we'll we'll watch a few videos of
kevin running and then we'll get to some
of the uh the um
alpha cuck and the dishonorable mention
because we also have those today as well
right well i mean what isn't with jared
i mean if i remember correctly there was
uh
there's always news about him um was it
i believe
it had to do
something with the saudi prince uh i
know greg had a story about it that i
was not able to
read myself i think it's behind a
paywall um
yeah but jared uh he's always behind
um
always behind something shady right
right and uh here
now that twitter is up let's just let's
just go to it you know check it out
because we're gonna have to be careful
with this um
brian suave
thread
the reason why is the brian suave threat
he really
he he incited boobs is what he incited
like right he did this thing where he's
like don't show your skin ladies on
twitter i don't want to see it because
i'm an alpha cuck which you know
right so the thing behind uh jared
kushner is the same thing right he's
always sleazy uh
uh always trying to make you know always
trying to profit off of an opportunity
and that opportunity was the white house
and so like in the article it says he
and his wife made over a half billion
dollars while working at the white house
which is [ __ ] insane uh that doesn't
count future earnings on connections
forged and promises made during his time
there i mean we're talking saudi prince
we're talking about this is the china
this is some of the china trades this is
all exactly where he was put into power
uh for
um
deals and positions and uh communication
with foreign leaders or entities and
then positioning himself either as a
business opportunity or some later back
end deal where he would get a kickback
or something like that
um
and that's
yeah it's just you know it time and time
again we see jared kushner try you know
he [ __ ] up covet he [ __ ] up this he
you know he tried to make deals in the
middle east you know he was claimed a
hero of of the jewish resistance um
you know and said that he
he uh
yeah he created right right you know and
and uh
and made up this whole narrative about
how we did that that's not at all what
happened we still have issues we still
have a conflict we you know it's
it's just one of those things where you
know
anyone related to trump is going to
claim victory uh unrightfully so
and going to create a revisionist story
or or uh
um
retelling
of what happened or rather what didn't
happen and then to tell you what
happened you know right right right so
and in that sense uh they're using that
any opportunity he had to make money he
was profiting off of any sort of you
know uh
any any talk right he'd go travel
somewhere as some like
representative and then you know
you know exchange some hands money here
there some deal later on years down the
line or a deal you know in that time you
know his family just financially
financially profit any way they can
right because that was i mean don't you
believe that that was some of the
intention
once they once they realized they had
won and they were going to enter the
white house because i don't think donald
trump ever decide like he was like oh i
want to be president right well here's
the thing like even
he didn't trump did not even expect no
one
no one on his team thought he would win
even that night i remember watching a
documentary um about kind of the rise up
of donald trump to the presidency and
what they discussed was you know omarosa
was like nobody thought he was going to
win they declared him a winner and
everyone was like where's trump where's
trump because he wasn't even ready
because he wasn't expecting to come out
and win
so they're like oh [ __ ] we gotta find
trump we gotta find trump and then to
bring him out to say like you know thank
you so much
you know we won and all that [ __ ]
but
that team didn't expect anything in term
close to a win they thought they were
gonna you know what the polls said was
they were gonna they were gonna lose but
for them it was a um
financial advantage because they were
able to take in donations
and it's one of those things where it's
like oh well the pac or the group has
money and now i'm able to use that money
you know however i want because you know
that's what happened you know when
you're and then you can say i want to
make it don't i wouldn't be surprised if
they were using that money then say like
well we've got some overflow cash we
want to you know use that money to an
organization right and do something
shady like they did well i mean this is
what this is this is what the tom
barrack and the the inaugural committee
when and some of the connection to
ivanka trump and the trump organization
where did that money go where did it
come from where did it go right and this
is all the same old story yeah inflated
prices for housing at the hotel there's
all sorts of things right it's like so
it's it's like not bone in the weeks
like bonehead of the decade type [ __ ]
yeah
okay well let's let's move on to uh
brian suave
salve salve swabbing salve
you know what
uh it sounds like
i i'm just confirming i did okay cool
he's gonna be on in one moment just give
me all right brian okay brian
patch us through just getting out of the
okay
one sec we'll stay we'll stay here
while um stay with us while we try to
get uh brian
uh
salve on the air here um it's just
completely ridiculous so what do you
what did you guys think of the everyone
everyone says hi gabe but you guys were
saying hi gabe to the to the to the the
um the the tech support guide that it's
your guys's twitter running ours is
running over here mine's going good
um i don't know if your guys is going
um
let's see what else we have here
hi gabe is so funny lisa says
well i don't know we'll find out really
quick as soon as this brian brian salve
uh makes an appearance apparently he's
gonna be a guest on the show here he's
gonna have a pop in uh caitlyn says
adidas got his ass yeah that is the one
thing that i can't show
on here i wish i could show it on here
but we post this on youtube so if i show
the the adidas boob tweet did you guys
see that the adidas boob tweet that was
the thing okay i think we got her i
think we got our guest uh here
um brian is that is that you brian hi uh
brian salve how you doing uh how are you
brian uh
great great great yeah i just wanted i
just wanted to come on and okay yeah and
and give my two cents here uh oh well
we're we're
my my audience is ready for you to give
your two cents everyone have their
comments ready here um for for brian
yeah this is your opportunity i just
want to uh explain myself okay i'm good
you know as a man okay as a as a as a
strong man as a strong man of christ
yes um
i just want to defend myself
and tell you that i'm right uh and
everyone else is wrong
okay uh i
uh you know i'm uh i i'm a man of god a
man of christ um you know what i say is
not to be uh taken in vain um but should
be followed uh for uh we are the
children of christ
and it is what christ would want uh
these women to not uh share these photos
of themselves so so brian so brian let
me ask you um
you you say you're a man and you're a
man's man yeah are you are you terrified
of women because it really seems like
you're terrified no no no no i'm not
are you scared of boobs because it it
seems like you're either really scared
of women or you're really scared of
boobs why would you
why would you even say something like
that like what that you're scared of
boobs
yeah why would you why where did you
even get that idea well i mean you tweet
a lot about how you don't want to see
women's skin and they either okay it's
like
you're okay like why am i now the victim
okay why are you coming after me
it's like that's not very christ-like of
you to attack a fellow
i'm not i i i'm not i am
i'm not i'm not a christian so well well
hopefully hopefully you will repent for
your sins and and uh and you'll find the
way of christ but i don't appreciate
being attacked here i i don't appreciate
uh being uh the victim um of this
onslaught attack onslaught of what you
know you posted the tweet on twitter you
said it i was speaking for god
so if god speaks through you through
your tweets what makes you think that
the the uh the boob tweets that women
post aren't speaking through god i mean
i kind of like that god better than your
god i'm just saying
it's it it makes me feel uncomfortable
okay boobs make you feel uncomfortable
or the fact that the boob god is better
than your god
there's a boob god well i mean i'm just
assuming i i don't believe in god but
you do and i'm saying yes i do i do
believe in god you said that god your
god speaks through you with the tweets
i'm just saying maybe there's a bit of
god his spirit speaks through me i don't
know anything about a boob god if there
was a boob god i would say he was the
devil himself satan
satan it's antichrist it's possible that
satan is the boob god but i mean you
know heaven or hell i'm going with the
boob god over your god who doesn't want
women to be able to okay okay
you know what next we're just going to
give everyone the equal rights right
like women are just all of a sudden are
going to be do whatever they want they
can just like vote
they can vote what yes they can they can
vote yep that's probably your problem
here is that you're you're in a
different timeline when did that happen
when did this happen this is this has
been a while ago brian and and honestly
not only can they vote they can have
twitter accounts too it's a thing that
women can do like it's a it's a liberty
that is given to i'm going to call folks
i'm going to have to pray on this i'm
going to have to pray on this pray what
are you praying for what do you bring
for for for god to forgive them forgive
them for what for
thinking thinking that they can that
they are
mightier than man
so you're mad that women are can be more
powerful than men
it's like how many ways do i have to put
it okay i i i don't i don't know i'm
trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
you're trying to say women make me feel
uncomfortable okay
why is why do they make you feel are you
do you not like women i love i love my
wife i love my wife okay i love my wife
i don't i if i love my wife i i i love
that's that's a sign that i love women
okay i love my wife
so just because you you say you love
your wife means that you love all women
is that what you're saying this is
duh it's like
i'm a feminist okay oh are you women
yeah
you heard it here folks you heard it
here folks
brian here is a is a feminist um you
know
so why then don't you want women to
express
their feelings and their bodies okay you
know what i feel like i've had enough
questions i feel like i'm being
persecuted like jesus christ himself
you're gonna put me on the cross and
just make me face all of these people
for judgment i don't think so you know
god forgive me for they know not what
they do okay that is what i have to say
to you you know yes women make me feel
uncomfortable okay there's a lot of
temptation a lot of temptation in my
pants okay
and i got to tell you this it makes me
super uncomfortable that when i have to
look at them online that that that they
are able to express themselves in a ways
that i can't okay that they're able to
be free and they're able to
just just just be who they are okay and
i i don't feel like i should be uh the
the the victim this attack uh that all
of these these these people are coming
at me for um but you know what i will
prevail i am a messenger of christ and a
messenger of god and i will tell you
this much that when more people come at
me it only makes me stronger
well i i appreciate that you think that
your weakness makes you strong because
it definitely is a weakness for you and
i i regret i regret putting you as a
contestant on the bone of the week i
definitely think you should have been
our alpha cuck of the week so brian i
really appreciate you stopping by
and um maybe we'll get gabe back here to
uh get his opinion on it thanks thanks
brian i'll thank you a lot yeah pray for
me
okay well
while we while we wait to see if we can
bring gabe back in the studio um let's
go to
let's go to
the
um the actual uh
thread here for brian you can see um
here that let's see oh wait wait wait a
second we got the twitter down see i'm
i'm all over the place he had me really
distracted
completely distracted there um of what
he was trying to do so here's the here's
the oh
here's the oh they're wanting me to sign
in oh my gosh
okay so here is
twitter is still down okay so here's the
brian
suave there's two of them look
salve there's two of them see that
there's two of them
oh here here's gabe back what did you
think of this guy would you like to do
this game sorry did you you were able to
i i patched through i don't know if you
guys yeah yeah you weren't there but we
got him through we got him he he's great
great okay yeah well not great but yeah
i mean i wasn't able to say great
through uh yeah he's he's he's a [ __ ]
bonehead and he definitely i'm and again
i'm i'm kind of sad we put him in his
contestant not the alpha cuck of the
week i told him that at the end
um you see there's two of these guys
now
obviously you know it's hard to confuse
um brian the one that was just on the
show here the christian pastor husband
father of five and classical school
founder what the [ __ ] does that mean
uh what is that i don't know what that i
don't know
but there's another one um the new
christian dom oh christian sounds like a
cult
called cult cult um but then uh there's
another one president of the national
police federation i don't know that
sounds like a better guy right right
i like i don't know about brian salves
in the world but two of them sound like
pretty shitty people oh that that see
that's why we can't go on this feed see
now i'm gonna have to blur on youtube
this guy
have you seen the
adidas tweet i have you i have yeah and
what did you think in the adidas tweet
more problem to them you know make that
[ __ ] feel uncomfortable obviously you
can't show it on here but you know
there's a okay i will say this there is
a lot of stuff on twitter uh
that you stumble across
um
you know and
um
but more yeah more power to adidas to to
share that you know empowering women to
say like you know not all women are the
same and everyone is different and
unique and these are the bodies that
we've been given by god
and you should uh you should feel
empowered you should feel uh
special you should feel you know
okay to to to be yourself you know don't
feel ashamed um
of
of uh of who you are
well right you know and if you go
through that feed because uh
the the the reason why we know this guy
is because he posted something like
women shouldn't post pictures of their
skin they shouldn't post weight loss
journey pictures they shouldn't post
pregnancy journey pictures and the other
day we actually showed a
a tweet where um kalyn i believe um
called him out on it and he posted a
picture of his of his wife while she was
pregnant on his the same account that he
was posting oh that's right yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
the hypocrite crazy well yeah oh who
would have thought so but but the the
the point is is that that this guy this
guy just wants to hate women um yeah
that's what these alpha cuts well he
just they just want control right they
want to control women your body
my choice my choice yep that's right
that's right speaking of speaking of
your body my choice let's go let's go to
um
let's go to um the uh alpha cuck let's
do alpha cuck first
we
we need to have a sound effect for that
i know i don't know if he's if it's
gonna be childish or if it should like
elf i think it should be like alphacock
yeah yeah oh look mom there's the alpha
cuck
what's an alpha cuck mom i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna make a video uh well or
maybe if you want you know i don't know
we'll find out if who how we do it but
maybe we should just be like you know a
little kid or a person who's like oh my
god look it's the alpha cuck and then
like it's whatever it is pull out zoom
and then it just shows boom there's the
alpha yeah or or you could like mom
what's an alpha cuck and then boom
there's the exactly here's an alpha
cucumber yeah yeah all right we'll work
on that yeah we'll we'll figure that out
yeah so so dave portnoy course we did a
lot of commentary on this week um we i
don't know probably an hour or so that
we've been talking because it ain't just
dave portnoy it's all the stoolies
themselves that are out exactly he's
just like he's the prez
the prez of alpha cox right exactly
that's that's how i see it he's the bro
that comes in and you know somehow makes
the vile disgusting rhetoric and
narrative that he pushes you know and
and they push
okay you know
right you know they're like oh well you
know
because you know they're partnering with
patriot takes and they're like oh you
know these guys are jewish and it's like
okay so is
dave pornoy but these dudes come out and
make death threats or harassment or
anti-semitism and it's okay because
you know
you're like everyone who complains is a
[ __ ] beta and we're just a bunch of
stooly bros we're [ __ ] uh juicing a
[ __ ] clown you know it's like that's
what they are you know
mckees right exactly like these dudes
want it so bad
you know it reminds me of the old brian
that was on you know yeah brian manly he
he's so manly he's terrified of women
like you think that's it a little bit
yeah so [ __ ] man i don't know what
you guys talked about but i could assess
from a non-uh clinical standpoint as a
non-physician right but i can say that
he probably has insecurities right and
you see a lot of these religious people
who will
uh who will map their own insecurities
and projection onto other people
and try to dig at you know
vulnerabilities or weaknesses to try to
make themselves power i mean like it's
why you see so many people in a cult
that that end up they know exactly where
to poke
on you and and get you to be
uh reactive to it so they know exactly
how to manipulate you later on and it's
the same thing here it's like you've got
some guy that is is trying to control
women
and trying to call out them for being
inappropriate for showing who they are
right and and
and how they look
and it's because he
is insecure about his own image whether
it's
he can't be
uh free who he is whatever he has some
trauma from his past you know whatever
it is it's one of those things where
he's like
uh i am you know i am as mighty as god
in jesus christ because i am a messenger
of god and what i say is truth and what
i say is holy and so if i do it
then you should do it and if you don't
do it then you're
but the but the stoolie thing is a
different kind of alka alpha cup right
like a different category because
they're not they're not in the uh i mean
there's a venn diagram for sure right
but do you know do you know that that
this brian how do you say his last name
salve salve yeah brian i keep wanting to
say salvia i that's what i keep wanted
to say you want to say salvia brian
salvia but it's brian salve i think
brian salve is that maybe why he puts
the little yeah brian salve this guy
went on a bar stool podcast and he's
like oh these guys are great they're
they they curse a lot and you have to be
careful that they curse a lot but boy oh
boy do they have a great view of women
they objectify the [ __ ] out of them and
i love it like this isn't it also dave
portnoy is going through his own
sexual harassment
i believe i don't know i you know the
only time i really collided worlds with
this dave portnoy is when he accused um
the mizellas brothers of being some you
know cabal well he didn't accuse him he
was retweeting and promoting it right
and the reason why is because there's
several twitter accounts that rag on him
and he feels like that myself brothers
have control of those accounts or
something that's why i think he entered
the chat in the first place and then he
got all the stoolies out um you know and
then they were calling and making death
threats i know they were in your tweet
they were in a few of my feeds but they
don't come after me like they do other
people um i know they were in your feet
saying racist ass [ __ ] um and they were
calling and threatening not just the
mizella's brothers but their families as
well it was [ __ ] gross and bio and i
know we went through that you know early
week so i don't want to i don't want to
touch too much on that because there's
there's already a video out there of us
tearing them apart yeah and you go to
the youtube channel and just uh go to
the one i think it's i think his name
might as touch receives death threats
yeah if you want to watch that if you
want to watch that but um but no
this this day portnoy thing in this
stooly bar store thing it leaks into
even like joe rogan like you said this
big venn diagram right and i talked
about it earlier about it because i
don't know if you've seen the video of
joe rogan like supporting bernie sanders
and yeah i i i watched that interview
where you know he he had him on you know
and i was like oh this is i thought it
was like this is a great opportunity to
to get a straightforward answer from
bernie sanders
to that group
how he converted i don't know but
he was on there was able to give that
message i thought it was a good
opportunity but i think you know back to
my point earlier that i made on the show
is the reason why joe rogan has been
able to build such a big audience is
because he reflects his guest right
that's why so many people have turned
him off and so many people have turned
him back on on the anti-back side
a lot of anti-vaxxers are listening to
him now that thought he was a socialist
in 2020 right right they're like oh yeah
joe rogan turned another cheek you know
and as soon as joe rogan turns another
cheek and he becomes quote-unquote a
socialist again you know and he's a
bernie bro again or whatever the [ __ ] it
is
the audience will turn again right yeah
because it's about selling averages it's
like it's like right before the pandemic
you know it was like you know a couple
weeks or whatever before the shutdown
happened he was in support of seems good
vaccines the best thing ever yeah he's
like that's because the doctor that was
sitting in front of him was saying that
so he said that right right joe rogan is
a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] he's he's just smart
enough to know that he has to he he has
to be who is in front of him right joe
rogan
he's kind of like
a mirror in some ways
um
and that i will agree when he has a
guest on you know most of the time he'll
agree with them you know there won't be
a lot of like back and forth like
disagreement i mean there was recently
when he had the other doctor or the
other scientists on who called him out
was like
uh
yeah yeah about cardinals yeah yeah was
actually yeah yeah he was saying the guy
was like actually it's much much lower
than you're claiming it is
for unvaccinated right and then he was
like oh well you know well basically
what the doctor was saying if you're
saying it's so bad that should be the
reason why you should get vaccinated
right right not not get back yeah yeah
yeah it's just as bad as you say right
the risk of it has higher with the
without the vaccine right and so and so
joe rogan i think is amir in many ways
that he will reflect the the the
the message that is being
said from the other person right the
person he brings on as a guest will say
something like yo yeah yeah totally you
know and uh whether it's you know
someone
obviously as of late he hasn't a lot he
hasn't had a lot of balance
on like actual thinking and actual
people with like a brain that
uh are willing to uh challenge this
insane
um
kind of thought that people have which
is like don't trust science
um because a lot of the guests had
recently are either people that don't
know anything about it or claim to know
stuff about it and are giving
um
fake information or false information or
disinformation or what have you and so
um you know i think for the most part
joe rogan is a mirror in that he will
typically kind of just say what the
other person is coming in yeah
absolutely and he'll take their position
if he has to attract that audience it's
like when alex jones came in he was you
know that's right he was a crazy [ __ ]
yeah speaking of misinformation and and
maybe um not knowing words and things uh
it brings us to our dishonorable mention
oh look at that representative marjorie
taylor green
marge here um she she was on uh tv or
some kind of trader tv and i've got the
let me let me pull up the uh
um she's being accused of being a super
nazi here but there's a video of her and
uh here republican accountability
project has it uh looks like she's on i
don't know some kind of [ __ ] trader
tv i don't know which channel which
trader channel this is this has 9.4
million views holy [ __ ]
um so and we're gonna watch some more
videos but this is her explaining why
the january 6th select committee is cold
soup let's listen
not only do we have the dc jail which is
the dc gulag but now we have nancy
pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of congress spine on the
legislative work that we do spying on
our staff and spying on american
citizens that want to come talk to their
representatives this government has
turned into something it was never meant
to be and it's time to make it in okay
so the the the one issue here that i
have is that if the federal authorities
are
receiving warrants to tap your phones
yeah and the [ __ ] quote-unquote spy
on you right
you're not in a good position now
whether you committed those crimes or
not i guess time will tell yeah but you
are but if you were you know you know
that's crazy because she said the same
stuff to me on a facetime call just did
she really yeah you know i think that
video is somewhere here let's find it
yeah oh is this is this the phone call
you reported yeah it's great yeah this
is it okay let's um let's let's see if
we can
see if we can get the recording of this
video call yeah goddammit
what do you want marge constituents want
to visit their representative the
capitol police will investigate them
which is absolutely absurd i don't know
anything about that but if i had to
guess it's probably because you're
involved with the insurrection they're
investigating our staff looking at their
social media they're even checking into
people that go to our events outside of
outside of washington because you
attempted a coup everything is
completely out of control not only do we
have the dc jail which is the dc gulag
again kind of your fault that they're
there but now we have nancy pelosi's
gazpacho police gazpacho police
oh no no no you mean gestapo police
gazpacho police gazpacho is a cold soup
gazpacho yeah that's a cold soup you're
getting confused with gestapo gazpacho
you just never mind spying on members of
congress spine on the legislative work
that we do
legislative work what the hell does
marge even do
so yeah so it appears it appears that
she's just calling people and saying
this over and over and over again yeah
it sounds like you know it's typical
republican fashion gqp they're trying to
push out the same talking points same
kind of word garbage right to to get it
out there if they say it enough times
you know very trumpism-like if they say
it enough times then they can
uh say look look all these people are
talking about it when it's really them
it's very much like trump where he's
like uh you know people are saying when
there's typically two things that are
being said here one no one ever said it
or two the only people that are talking
about it or saying it is him himself
and that's that's that's like trump
talking about many people are saying
that you have to flush 10 to 15 times to
to get stuff down the toilet you know
only to find out that he was probably
well
right well i mean the thing right the
thing well you get he got full
earlier i said this he already had two
boxes of top secret documents right and
he was full so he couldn't eat anymore
so right and he was reserving too much
fiber right you know way too much fiber
so then he had to resort to flushing it
down the toilet i mean
what are you gonna do when a guy's full
after two boxes what are you gonna do
it's like either give him a better
toilet or
you know
bring in joe the plumber you know right
right right
i don't know what that guy's doing these
days like what is joe the plumber up to
you know i i mean maybe maybe maybe he's
making visits to the right i think he
was just like the toilet he was just
like working the toilet and like
plunging and he was like
this is the only uh because i know he he
tried to run for congress
uh in ohio i don't think that was
successful the plumber did joe the
plumber which else his name isn't joe
the plumber by the way his name is like
uh brad something it's not even joe
no
uh oh samuel j
uh werzelbacher oh okay yeah that sounds
you know joe the but it was joe the
plumber because this was back this is
back with obama yeah this is obama
mccain days yeah this is also
joe the plumber and megan mccain do not
like each other oh they don't no they
don't because
i don't know they i don't know i'm not
sure exactly oh okay their feud is but i
just know they don't like each other
it's definitely if you were to google it
i'm sure you could find the answer but
yeah they don't like each other at all
speaking speaking of not liking someone
and not liking to answer questions
speaking of that oh yeah we have our we
have our uh i was going to say the whole
republican party but yeah well right
right but we have kevin kevin mccarthy
he played forest gump this week i don't
know yeah
run kevin run yeah run kevin run so
let's let's give him his due here for
his win on bone end of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so kevin mccarthy wins but the question
is why did he win
what what did he do um rachel scott was
trying to ask him a question i tried to
ask the gqp leader oh excuse me gop
leader yeah about the rnc's resolution
describing the january 6 as legitimate
political discourse and of course kevin
mccarthy can't even engage in actual
legitimate political discourse here he
told me to make an appointment to his
office insisting it's not good to answer
questions in the hallway let's watch the
video evidence here it's not very long
you don't make it an appointment
okay it's not good it's not going to be
doing anything it's not good to do
interviews and all that
i'm walking i'm going you know i'm
pretty excited to watch uh kevin
mccarthy when he does the nfl combine
and do the 40-yard dash because i i hear
rumor has it that he can uh he can run a
4.2 well he's running fast here you know
what you know what i want to give him a
little leeway here what if he's got a
turtle head poking right like this like
a little groundhog like right right this
guy he's prairie dog in here
i mean he may have really had to take a
[ __ ] i mean listen i why not just say
what's happening like listen uh i need a
bio break i'll be right back right you
know if you want to follow me into the
bathroom like people did with cursing
cinema totally right well you know they
used to interview jay um um lbj when he
was taking a [ __ ] did you know that
uh
he would take a [ __ ] and they he would
prop the door open and and the reporters
would come in into the oval office like
sit in a chair outside the bathroom i
mean that is a true definition of open
door policy well yeah well yeah lbj
would do interviews while he was taking
the show i mean you're a busy guy you're
a busy guy
yeah i i i also look at it and i say
like listen man if that guy's gonna be
as real and not hide you know props to
him to to say listen i'm the president i
got a lot of [ __ ] going on i don't have
time to have my diet literally literally
literally yeah right right and uh i'm
gonna drop the old deuce right now
um let me uh and i'll you know i said
yesterday um
i said turns out
uh
trump wasn't able to perform the duties
of his presidency because he flushed him
down the toilet duties how did you get
duties like d-o-o-d-o yes yeah like he
took a duty yeah a little dad joke
yeah yeah you know
so so kevin mccarthy i mean i i believe
the reason why i didn't want to answer
the question is because there's no real
good answer to the question um but maybe
maybe maybe just maybe he had to drop a
deuce and he had he had to go do his
duties as you would say and um but you
know maybe i don't think so but that
might be the possibility here it's quite
possible homie had to drop uh kids off
the pool you know i'm telling you dude
all right let's see take the browns to
the super bowl even though they're not
in it this year well you know it happens
that way there is there is a good
version um
and the version that i'm looking for is
the daily show i don't know if you've
seen their version of the video
no i have not
um the daily shows version of this is
fantastic if if i can find it in this
thread i was gonna do one with the uh
yakity yak song you know the the benny
hill one because i've done it the one
that i did for margie taylor green and
matt gates that like blew up and i was
gonna do it again but i i didn't have
time to do it and then uh might just
touched it so i was like all right i'm
glad somebody oh yeah
and they they actually took the the
footage from like um there's another
clip that they had where he was out in
the back like before yeah from before
like the hallway that he came out of
like and because there was another
reporter trying to follow him right i'm
trying to get the the answer he's like
ah yeah kevin run let's hear let's do
this um if twitter will cooperate here
daily show
do we find it here
[Music]
i want to show this video since you
haven't seen it and then and then we'll
um
we'll throw out here if i can find it
damn it you know hey we were talking
about doing duties looking here look at
that
yeah you know it happens
um so
well i i can't find it i'm sorry it's
okay you failed me today it's fine i
will forgive you but it'll take me some
time give me the rest of the day to do
well we hope we hope kevin mccarthy if
he did have to go take a big huge [ __ ]
that he didn't use
his his top secret documents um to
whitewater yeah to wipe his eyes
listen i'm just saying there's a video
coming out soon maybe tomorrow i don't
know okay where there are some documents
and some other things that are
discovered by the archives team
oh okay some pretty juicy stuff you know
juicy juicy juicy juicy yeah you know
maybe some of it has some stuff on it
you know right right okay
yeah okay
well let's give let's give old forrest
gump i mean uh kevin his dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
one last time one last time for kevin
kevin mccarthy boom congratulations
kevin
of the week thank you for joining us a
bonus week stick around we'll be we'll
we'll stay after the song we'll be right
back here to uh give you some
announcements
[Music]
[Applause]
all right welcome welcome welcome back
thanks for joining us today on friday
did you like the moment of the week um
there was some crazy [ __ ] that happened
during moon end of the week there crazy
ass [ __ ] we had twitter support come on
i'm sure we'll cut that out and probably
post it somewhere on twitter that
twitter support came and helped the tony
michaels podcast get back online
we had twitter support right here they
didn't know twitter was up twitter was
down they didn't know if they wanted to
trend up or trend down they wanted
twitter down to trend up they couldn't
figure it out they couldn't figure it
out but they got twitter back up i hope
you guys have your twitter back up
i hope you got it
uh and uh
listen every single weekday noon eastern
11 center right here on youtube twitter
twitch when twitter is working when it's
not down we are here look at this we got
popock still up here
this is that's there we go
you know what i'm i'm going to
shoot some merch here yeah go go get
some [ __ ] merch we got the [ __ ]
merch store open we also had the podcast
upgrade fun going go check that out over
at the tonymichaels.com the link is in
the bio
thetonymichaels.com check out the
[ __ ] hats we got [ __ ] shirts um we
got some stay pissed mugs all kinds of
good stuff over there there's actually
two merch stores so go check that out um
and if you can give to the podcast
upgrade fund dollar two dollars whatever
you can it helps out here at the podcast
do that
and really until monday
until monday surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking